Au milieu des décombres, ces pompiers
recherchent d'éventuelles victimes
des derniers bombardements depuis le
début de l'invasion russe,
la ville de harki vit au rythme
quotidien
des bombes au 33ème jour de guerre.
Kiev et Moscou vont une nouvelle fois
tenter de négocier
les modalités d'un cessez le feu en
Turquie.
Devant des médias russes, le président
ukrainien annonce mettre
le statut de neutralité de l'Ukraine sur
la table.
L'une des exigences de la Russie, elle
doit être un pont.
-La question des garanties
de sécurité pour l'Ukraine est bien à ce
point des
des négociations et compréhensible pour
moi et il est en discussion.
Il est étudié en profondeur par la.
-En cas d'accord, ce statut
neutralité sera soumis à référendum,
précise le président Zelensky.
Ces négociations débutent après
l'annonce d'un changement
de stratégie militaire pour la Russie.
Désormais, l'objectif de Moscou serait
entièrement dirigé vers
le Donbass, à l'est de l'Ukraine.
Après plusieurs semaines de
bombardements, les habitants de Nikolaev,
près d'Odessa, ont connu leurs premières
heures de calme.
Mais si les Russes ont quitté les lieux,
c'est d'abord
le fait de la résistance de l'armée
ukrainienne et de
la population qui a quitté ce
véhicule,
traversé notre village quand il est
passé.
On lui a crevé les pneus et il a fini sa
course ici.
Quand il venait soudain, c'est là qu'on
l'a complètement détruit.
L'annonce d'une concentration des forces
russes vers l'est laisse
les Ukrainiens sceptiques.
Samedi, Lviv, la grande ville de
l'Ouest,
a été touchée par des bombardements.
L'autre inquiétude concerne la ville de
Marioupol.
La grande ville portuaire subit
un siège sans fin depuis plusieurs
semaines.
La situation humanitaire y est
catastrophique.
2.000 civils auraient été tués, selon
les autorités locales, et les tentatives
de
mise en place d'un corridor humanitaire
ont
toutes échoué pour l'instant.
Une nouvelle opération d'évacuation se
prépare
actuellement sous l'égide de
de la France, de la Turquie et de.